[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh mr matt damon has just joined us matt
damon has just joined us
i'm just looking at your bio matt how
many sports movies have you been in
oh uh i don't know um
off the top of my head like uh the there
was the rugby one
there was uh invictus um
i don't know man i don't know we you're
looking at my bio you'll probably have a
better idea
i'm not sure how many movies i've done
i've probably done more than 50. so
all right um i got you as an extra in
field of dreams
that's true yeah ben and i were extras
in that actually
just to just to go to fenway we uh
we were extras in uh in field of dreams
like there were probably three thousand
extras in a big crowd scene
uh when kevin costner and james earl
jones are at the baseball game
but how old are you do you get to talk
to costner
you know what we did uh costner came out
and hung out with the extras um
and uh and we ben and i went and struck
up a conversation with him
um and he probably gave us five minutes
like he was incredibly uh
generous did you did you pitch a movie
did you do your
elevator pitch no no no we just told him
we told him we knew we wanted to be
actors i was probably 17 and ben was
probably 15 and
we were we were already traveling to new
york and auditioning
and uh you know we were like we have
agents
[Laughter]
and he was really you know he was great
he was
you know it's like these two kids who
were like you know and it happens to me
all the time people come
you know kids come up and like i'm
really i want to be an actor and it's
like
fantastic good for you man like go get
them
school ties you were a running back you
had fumble issues
yeah i did i did i mean it's prep school
football in 1955 we were running out of
a wing t
so i don't think it was like a very
serious sports movie but
we did go and and uh and and practice
like a month early like they wanted to
make sure that
um you know that that we that we knew
what we were doing
and then you lost your girlfriend to
brendan frazier
listen it can happen it's an occupation
brendan's a great guy yeah you're not
the first guy to lose a girl to brendan
frazier
i die yeah i doubt i am the first guy to
lose a girl to brendan
is rounders a sports movie
that's a good question i mean you'd
probably have to ask professional poker
players i mean i think they would tell
you it's a sport
um but uh but uh i mean i
yeah i mean it's yeah they i i would say
i mean just
the architecture of the script yes it's
a sports movie like it's it's exactly
how you would design it if we were
wrestling or playing basketball so
and then in that sense it's a sports
movie who's more
complicated or maybe interesting
john malkovich or ed norton
listen those are two of our best actors
you know on the pla you know the two
two of the best that our country is
produced so uh i i wouldn't say either
is less complicated than the other
they're both great guys and they're both
a lot of fun to work with
um they're both very serious but they
both
work out of a place of total joy and
they want it to be fun
so uh so so no i i
i couldn't really draw a distinction
between them let me give you the
official introduction here he's uh matt
damon actor producer screenwriter
and tom brady apologist it says here as
an apologist
i don't apologize for anything listen i
love that guy
i make no apologies okay if the bucks
played the patriots in the super bowl
who would you root for tom brady okay
all right
the uh the movie is called stillwater
opens in theaters this friday
and uh so you're you're a guy from
oklahoma
stillwater you travel to france your
daughter is there in prison
now let me do the let me see if i can do
the uh connect the dots
abigail breslin is your daughter yeah
abigail breslin played in little miss
sunshine she was the star greg kinnear
played in little miss
sunshine as her dad you guys played
uh stuck on you the fireley brothers and
then you met your wife when you were
doing that movie how did i do
you got everything right okay well
that's it that's
nothing else to talk about there matt um
how do you nail an
accent how do you know when okay i got
that oklahoma accent
uh well it's it's tough i mean you gotta
you gotta spend a lot of time with it i
i went down i actually worked a lot in
texas when i was uh
in my 20s just a lot of the movies i got
were down there so i lived down in that
part of the world
quite a bit and and love it down there
and
so i kind of i i remember the rhythm and
the cadence and and how people talk but
um but
you know this was a very specific place
and and a very specific type of guy he's
a roughneck
um and so i just went down to oklahoma
and hung out with those guys
um and that's usually the best way to do
it and i also have a dialect coach tim
monik who i
you know we can we can analyze and sit
there and write down on paper exactly
what's happening but
but the best way to do it usually is to
listen tim will have uh
on file a lot of different voices and a
lot of different and and we'll just
listen and
and and just start to get into the uh
you know you kind of buy osmosis you
eventually eventually pick it up but but
you you do some technical work so you
understand what's happening but
there's no there's no substitute for
just going there and hanging out
but when you go to hang out how long
does it take for the locals to allow you
to kind of absorb whatever you're
absorbing
yeah that's a good question because you
know i mean we got down there and
and those guys were understandably wary
of us you know they're like what are you
like hollywood
like liberal what are you doing down
here like making a movie about a rough
neck like
what what are your intentions you know
what i mean like you know
and uh and i think it you know once they
realized like we
you know we we were just trying to get
it right and uh
and this is a movie that has a lot of
empathy and compassion for this
character
that i play you know it's it's it's a
movie about this journey this guy goes
on
so the once you know they once they
realized that
that we weren't there to poke fun at
them or anything that we were there to
really
you know to do get it accurately they
they were incredible
and and and really brought us in i mean
you know
it's one of the great things about my
job i get to like parachute into
somebody else's life who's like
you know i mean that roughneck culture
in oklahoma is so different from
you know cambridge massachusetts where i
grew up you know i mean it really it's
like
it's like a different world and and and
i can't get it right unless
unless those guys let me come in and and
and
and see see what their life is like and
uh
and and and and talk to them about it
and uh gather information and and they
just were they just could not have been
more helpful
do you sprinkle in mcconaughey type
accent
like accidentally his accent's a little
softer than the one in this movie
uh you know and and i mean matthew's you
know matthew
can can play it up or down matthew
actually can do a perfect impression of
me
um because i was you know when we did
interstellar together
you know he he was like all right you do
this impression of me and i was like
yeah i just found out that like my voice
could sound like yours if i just dropped
down a little bit and went south
and he and i'm like if you come up and
go north you'll you'll you'll get me
perfectly and he started doing it we
were in a van in
iceland and i was crying i was like
because he's like he's perfect but he
but he he was like i need a catch phrase
i need a catch phrase for you
because i because i would do like you
know hey i'm going to take my shirt off
you know like you know he's like he's
like you have a catchphrase i need a
catchphrase so
we got to come up for with a catchphrase
for matthew and then and then you can
hear
could he fool your wife
we have a similar vocal quality in a
certain
like if we if we aim at it like we we
could
i i'm sure he could over the phone uh
fool her yeah well you know what bagger
vance i forgot to mention that
another sports movie okay well you had
to bring it up
wait you're not you're all in on bagger
vans
no well listen i i i i love the
experience
i love you know robert redford and will
and charlize and like you know
that that the experience was great and i
learned how to play golf but i've never
picked up a golf club before that movie
i grew up in a city
and i picked that and i so that i look
at that movie and cringe when i look at
my
my golf swing but to be fair i look at
my golf swing and cringe today
so
[Laughter]
uh i we we had an idea for funny or die
let's say you go to some place in europe
and you just start running and
jumping into a car and you have some guy
who's chasing you
people is people will think that there's
another born movie being shot
like you just do it out of nowhere you
just start running down the street
yeah and just jump into like a smart car
yeah
yes yeah you got to get me out of here
right now we got to move we got to move
right yeah
yeah yeah yeah it might work i
also might get like like hit in the head
with a hammer you could
you could you could but it'd be funny or
die that'd be the die part of it
it would it would it's the actual the
first skit that for funny or die
how old is too old to be jason bourne
uh listen if there's a good story
it's you know you're never too old to be
that guy you know and i you know
look eventually i mean i would love to
do another one and and uh
you know and and at some point i'm gonna
have to pass it on
you know i i would love to figure out a
way to hand it off to somebody
um you know a man or a woman i mean oh
you know like
you know to you know as if that name is
uh
you know a name only uses and it can be
anybody right like
um so uh but but but we gotta come up we
it's gotta be good i i just
you know i love those movies i i you
know we we all there are a lot of
really great friends of mine who who put
a lot into those and
and we don't want to mess it up so so if
we do it's got to be good
what was the stunt you did in any of the
bourne movies where you look back and go
what the hell was i thinking
i think on the first one i caught when
when i climb out
down the embassy in prague i remember
shooting that
and um i was in a harness on the side of
this building and it was it was a
particularly cold day in the winter in
prague so
let's say it was like minus 10. and
i was so cold and i'm hanging on this
thing and i'm a couple hundred feet up
in the air
and trying to grip this wall and i just
remembered and i was about
29 30 years old and i was like what am i
doing this is crazy
but uh but the see the sequence is great
it was worth it
and and matt wants everybody to know
that this new movie
stillwater with has gotten great reviews
standing ovation at uh
khan right yeah
yeah yeah it was uh it was it was great
and uh
and um it was also the first time i'd
been in a movie theater
in you know almost two years and so
so i got i got oddly emotional i was
like i got choked up and i
get kind of snuck up on me um but uh but
it was it felt great to be
in a movie theater again you know i mean
i'm so i mean look i'm
i'm i'm like everyone else i'm so sick
of this covet thing
i i you know it's like i can't get back
to normal life fast enough but
you know i know it's gonna i know we're
delta variants and all that stuff
and we're dealing with it but but uh i
mean i miss hanging out with people
but also and you want people to know
this isn't like liam neeson and taken
because people i think yeah right
because it feels like uh oh
somebody's going over to some place in
europe to get
his daughter back yeah thank you for
bringing that up man because
particularly for like
people who listen to this show uh which
i do um
you know uh the the movie might look
like
one of those movies um because the setup
is like that right
you know uh his daughter's in jail he
you know he
you know it's like one of those things
and uh it's it's
you're expecting that kind of liam
neeson hero or jason bourne for that
matter to come in and
and you know kick some ass and uh have
this have the skill set to kind of solve
all the problems
this is decidedly not that movie it's
this is a movie about a real
dude a real like a roughneck who's in
that situation
who comes over and he's his daughter's
five years into a
you know this sentence for a crime that
she didn't commit and he's
he's been an absentee bad and so he's
been a he's been a he's been
he's messed up this relationship and
he's
trying to repair the damage that he's
done with his
you know by his failures and he's
doesn't have the skill set and he
doesn't have you know and he's just
doing his level best to help his
daughter and and so it's a it's it's
much more of a drama than a thriller
uh so just anybody listening to it if
you go there expecting like
any kung fu you're going to be sorely
disappointed
uh it's it's a movie about real people
where are you right now what
who came up with the background there in
that room i'm in
i'm in brooklyn new york i'm at the one
hotel where uh
they they're doing this press junket and
uh yeah look at these there's uh
jars of i don't know what those are what
is that i don't know it's what hipsters
do
yeah but you live in brooklyn don't you
i do i live down the street but i didn't
want to do this in my house
i got a nice church and state man
i got to keep these things separate five
years ago today
was the last time we had you on is it
really that long
five years ago today where the hell are
you did you get too big
for us because if you didn't clearly not
okay now you're crawling back i knew it
well
i knew it for a little dp in my life and
i think
that you called in and and you
you called in eight years ago from your
home in miami
and paulie picked up and he said oh
you're calling from miami and you go
i thought my number was blocked
and we had caller idea uh idea and you
asked paulie my producer hey how do i
how do i get this blocked this number
paulie's like
i don't know don't you have like agents
don't you have people who help you with
this stuff
that's really funny because i still have
the same number and it's and it's
blocked and everybody complains like if
ever if i facetime someone they're like
i knew it was you because it would fly
i don't know how it got blocked and i
didn't remember that
so maybe maybe paulie's the one who told
me how to block it
and that was the genesis of all of it
paulie used to have
matt's number down and i can't deny her
no say it to him and then he'll see if
it's true or not i don't want to turn to
jason bourne on me
i've got i've got my phone on me you
gotta have it
is this your number hey good luck with
the movie and um
and you know don't wait another five
years i don't want to man okay hey
listen we i gotta ben and i have this
movie the last duel coming out in
october i'll come back and talk to you
in a couple months that would be great
hey it's great to talk to you again and
thank you matt
go bucks go tom
that's uh matt damon the movie is called
stillwater opens in theaters
july 30th